Okay.
Let's see where these fit in.
Let's start with GitHub.
GitHub is a service that let's users interact with Git.
There are couple of different ways that we could've represented this.
Maybe GitHub operates on Git, or maybe even that GitHub refers to Git.
But I chose to represent it as Git being a part of GitHub.
Now let's think about remotes.
A remote in your local repository is basically a reference to
another repository, so we can say that remote refers to repositories.
Also when you clone a repository, a remote gets set up for
you automatically, so we can say that clone operators on remotes.
So remote goes here.
At this point the remaining two spots are exactly the same.
They both operate on both remote and branch.
So we could put these in either spot.
Let's check that this actually makes sense.
When you push or pull, you have to specify what branch you want to push or pull.
So, it definitely operates on branches.
Pull takes a branch from a remote and brings it to your local repository.
And push does the opposite, taking a branch and pushing it to a remote.
So these do both operate on a remote as well.
All right.
We now have our Concept Map up to this point.